you
[Music]
good morning Hank it's Thursday December
20th and today's video comes in for very
special parts one your song I liked it
although it did kind of make me sad it
also made me really proud of you because
I realized that you have completed the
song challenge and not to toot our horns
but we've also almost completed the
project that is Brotherhood 2.0 and I
have to say Hank I'm really impressed
with us because you know my record of
completing things that I set out to do
not so great I mean like the sprawling
young adult novel about eco-terrorists
living on a Pacific island never
completed my promise to wait ten pounds
less On January 1st 2008 then I weighed
on January 1st 2007 not completed
although I do still have 11 days to lose
eight pounds look Hank yummy makes your
tongue green I mean honestly Hank all I
can do is eat healthy and hope that the
weight comes off you know getting Hank
and Katherine their Christmas presents
before Christmas not completed oh that
reminds me part 2 your Christmas
presents hey Hank
ah your Christmas presents might not
arrive by Christmas now Hank I bought
them before Christmas so I don't even
think this is really my fault I think
it's much more default to the United
States Postal Service who and this was a
surprise to me has not yet invented a
machine that will allow a package to go
from one place to another place
instantly I mean Hank we can beam
Captain Kirk across the universe but we
can't send a package from Indiana to
Montana
we can't beam Captain Kirk across the
universe really I mean they did it do
you guys never see those documentaries
part three your punishment Hank it's no
secret that nerdfighters get a little
bloodthirsty around punishment time I'm
referring specifically to the young
person who said that we should make you
cry ten thousand tears and then boil
those ten thousand tears and cook you in
them so before I talk about your actual
punishment options I want to talk about
some of the punishments that
nerdfighters suggested that I had to
dismiss Hank she'd have to release a
squirrel or another rodent that won't
hurt him into his undergarments I'm
troubled by the notion that someone
somewhere believes that it would not be
harmful to release a squirrel into one's
undergarments I mean I think it would be
triply harmful it would be harmful to
the person it would be harmful to the
squirrel and perhaps most of all it
would be harmful to the undergarments
what the buck says that you should have
to watch
actually Tisdale's YouTube channel gosh
buck he just texted communicated with me
it's not like he killed a man Hank
should have to consume an entire
blenderize Hummer
that's an excellent punishment idea
because it would require the purchase of
a Hummer and we all know that the only
thing Hank hates more than fuel
inefficiency is spending money but the
more I thought about it the more I felt
like eating more than a thousand pounds
of steel and plastic and leather might
be harmful to Hanks health particularly
considering that there's only 11 days
left in Brotherhood 2.0 so he'd have to
average like a hundred pounds a day
I think Hank should have to purchase an
Easter Bunny costume and then get into a
battle royale with the nearest shopping
mall Santa that's an excellent
punishment but it might lead to the
premature end Brotherhood 2.0 because I
don't know if you're able to vlog from
prison making me to penguin now
obviously that's much more of a
punishment for the penguin than it is
for Hank and the penguin didn't do
anything wrong
I think the punishment would be to make
a penguin eat Hank but I think
ultimately having a penguin eat Hank is
too harsh of a punishment for the crime
I mean it's not watching ashley tisdale
youtube channel harsh but it's harsh
Hank as for your actual punishment I
have settled on two suggestions
the nerdfighters will vote for their
favorite between the two and then you
will have to do that punishment option
one you will eat a blenderize Christmas
meal this meal will include at the very
least Christmas ham eggnog and Christmas
cookies option two you will give a live
performance of nerdfighting songs in a
public place the concert will last for
at least one hour and you accept
donations which will be given to
charities that decrease worldsuck
also if at any point you need to drink
anything to wet your whistle while
performing you can only drink peeps
blended with Strawberry Hill
nerdfighters to vote leave a comment for
your preferred punishment part for the
scavenger hunt today's clue is going to
lead to three numbers on three separate
continents but it all starts here in the
UK and remember scavenger hunters phone
calls are now strictly against the rules
Hank thanks again for all those great
songs I'll see you tomorrow